and here the astronauts come 52 years to
the day he watched the first moon
landing
jeff bezos walked out to make his own
history in space
alongside him and his brother mark
veteran pilot wally funk
and student oliver damon about to become
the oldest
and youngest ever in space
the new shepard rocket was built with
bezos's billions
a testament to his desire to build what
he calls a road to space
go jeff go marco wally go oliver you are
going for space in the capsule
66 miles up they experienced a few
minutes of the weightlessness
of zero gravity it did everything you
thought it would happen
dude look oliver
oh that's great can you move your head a
little while oh yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
the journey back was equally smooth
first the booster rocket
and then the capsule touching down on
the desert surface
completing the mission to the delight of
those on board
welcome back new shepherd's first
human crew
[Music]
they emerged now officially astronauts
in another leap for the space tourism
race oh my god
my expectations were high and they were
dramatically exceeded
the most profound piece of it for me was
looking out
at the earth and looking at the earth's
atmosphere
every astronaut everybody who's been up
into space
they say this that it changes them and
they look at it and they're kind of
amazed and
awe struck by the earth and its beauty
but also by its fragility
and i can vouch for that and who made
this billionaire's dreams come true
i want to thank uh every
amazon employee and every amazon
customer
because you guys paid for all this so
seriously for every amazon customer out
there
and every amazon employee thank you from
the bottom of my heart jeff bezos was of
course beaten into space by sir richard
branson but both men say this isn't
about a contest
they believe there are enough willing
customers to go around
and they believe that in the next decade
space tourism will be a multi-billion
dollar business
bezos said seeing earth from above
reinforced his commitment to tackling
climate change
what another billionaire's trip to space
means for the rest of us is the question
whatever the answer there is no doubt
this is the dawn of a new space age
greg milam sky news texas
you